we have six-year-olds who are being told
they can choose their own gender behind
their parents backs one of the things
that's happening this school year is
it's been exposed that there are gender
plans where students have a different
identity at school and a different name
at school than they have at home and the
schools are keeping this secret from the
parents
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is from
the foundation for individual rights in
education who is the author of
how politicized classrooms harm kids and
ruin our schools and what we can do
about it bonnie snyder welcome to
trigonometry
welcome welcome i mean thank you for
having me this is great
it's a pleasure to have you on the show
listen for before we get into talking
about uh all of this stuff uh please
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
through life that brings you to be
sitting here talking to us about all of
this
yeah i i guess you could say i'm sort of
a self-ejected academic i was
planning to become a
shakespearean an english professor
teaching shakespeare and
in that journey i encountered early
waves of postmodernism deconstruction
deconstructionism that sort of tipped me
off that there was a big problem in the
academy
and i had to completely change course
and a lot of the things that i think
we'll be talking about today really
originated in the humanities so i think
that i had an early view to these issues
uh and then i ended up
becoming
a doctor of higher ed administration
specifically to confront the problems i
saw in the academy
and i did not succeed in being hired
because i think that there are
ideological litmus tests that are
imposed in the academy and i always knew
the right answer to the questions they
were asking but i i chose honestly
uh and so i ended up being an adjunct
for a number of years which actually was
fine and i learned a lot on that journey
uh but ultimately i found my way to the
foundation for individual rights and
education where we defend free speech
and a lot of the enlightenment values
that i think are under threat today
and one of the things for us in the uk
we are starting to see
a few hints of the stuff that you talk
about bleeding through
into our school so i actually got a
message from a friend saying that at my
old school uh they now are demanding
that staff uh put their pronouns in
their emails or announce them at the
beginning of classes and all of this
type of thing
give us the broader picture like when we
talk about
people
you know use words like indoctrination
and post-modernism like what is
happening in american schools
oh gosh there's a lot of things going on
i think that um
i would say right now it kind of depends
when you ask that question right now i
would say that we're seeing the
importation of an alternate morality
uh into our classrooms without agreement
from the public we're seeing a lot of
deception being used parents being kept
in the dark which obviously and now that
things are coming to light and being
exposed has raised a lot of legitimate
anger righteous anger uh we are seeing
um
you know we're seeing the politician
politicization of the classroom we are
seeing i think for a long time we talked
about diversifying the curriculum and i
think that really that we've done a lot
of work diversifying the curriculum
curriculum we've moved on i think to
radicalizing the curriculum
and this school year i think we are
seeing
sexualization of the curriculum which is
a really interesting twist i've you know
i've been at this a while and i've
noticed that every school year the
the um
angle seems to change uh so those are
just a few things that are going on it
we're seeing just we're seeing contempt
for parents
coming from school teachers uh and we're
seeing i think teachers who are
you know k-12 teachers in america who
are presenting themselves as though
they're college professors and they seem
to think that they have academic freedom
which they don't the speech is
considered in public schools to be hired
speech government speech i'm hearing
teachers also talking about this is my
classroom and in my classroom this is
how it's going to be but really the
classroom belongs to the taxpayer
so
a lot there's many layers of of things
that are happening simultaneously
and bonnie when did you first start to
notice this when was it that you got the
first inkling that something untoward
was happening
well as i mentioned uh back in graduate
school i was exposed to
deconstructionism which i i called
destructionism
and i chose to leave uh and and you know
bonnie i'm just going to interrupt you
there because what we're going to be
doing throughout this interview is we're
going to be using academic terms which i
think you know you and i and constantine
might know but there'll be people who
are really interested in this subject
who who don't know could you just
explain to us what deconstructionism is
firstly
no i can't because
that's what
deconstructionism is i mean part of it
is that it is so
uh the writings are so obtuse so hard to
understand that that's part of what
drove me away from it you know that it i
would say um
two things one is that they were
starting to play with language in ways
where they were arguing that nothing
means anything uh and there was this
great leveling taking place where they
were telling me that you know the
greatest works of english literature as
agreed upon by centuries of scholars who
had studied this are no better than
reading a restaurant menu that it's all
in the reading it doesn't matte and you
know there's the idea of intention it
doesn't matter what the
author intended to say all that matters
is what i take from it and i could take
as much meaning from a restaurant menu
as you could take from war and peace and
this to me just seemed like utter
nonsense i went to my advisors and i
said look i i don't even know what to
say and the the interesting thing was
that my the faculty
where i was was completely dispirited
like you just looked at them and the
light had gone out of their eyes these
were like soulless zombies walking
around who had completely given up who
were just going through the motions and
i i looked at them and i was like i
don't want to do this anymore because
literature is supposed to be uplifting
it's supposed to speak to these
transcendent issues so
and
so that aside i recognize i could say
more about that i mean one thing they
said to me which i think is relevant is
they said well we're just deconstructing
the canon the literary canon these books
that you know
students read over and over again year
after year and i said well that's
interesting for you
but can i first learn the canon before i
do
because i think that that's an
interesting activity for one generation
of scholars who have already had the
classical training uh and i feel like
this is what's happening now in our
schools is that we're kind of giving
students the rubble after everything has
been deconstructed and saying isn't this
fascinating look at what we've done for
you and it's just is a mess it's an
incoherent mess so
when i saw it again was when my younger
daughter was in i moved her to a private
school having been in public school
government school beforehand and
she was given
the communist manifesto to read which i
don't mind because that's a really
important book but then she was asked to
debate the merits of capitalism versus
communism
they were given nothing to read on
capitalism and her class concluded that
communism is a better system than
capitalism
well eight-year-olds would do that yeah
these are 10th graders as a matter of
fact yeah and some of these kids in this
class actually literally had parents who
own a factory which i find hilarious
but they know what they're supposed to
say to get through with it and what
really bothered me was when i confronted
them they lied to me
which is a whole other level and there's
a lot of lying going on which is a very
marxist tactic and um i i often point
out i probably can find it i bet i can
pull this out
um
you know when i was an undergrad i went
to harvard and i was assigned one book
more than once uh there was only one
book i was assigned multiple times and
that was the communist manifesto i was
assigned it six times uh and which i
find hilarious and uh
all i can say is i know it when i see it
because i've been exposed to it
and uh
just as a curious aside why were you
assigned the communist manifesto six
times was it because you were they were
trying to get you to understand how
terrible this ideology was
good question i'm not sure why i was
assigned it six times i i did take some
russian history so those i understand
because it was the height of the cold
war so in that sense i did study with
richard pipes who was an advisor to
reagan i believe and uh so i think a
couple of times it was to get me to
understand how pernicious this ideology
can be but then i was an english major i
wasn't a you know a politics major i
think
it is considered
fundamental to
tearing apart literature
that's what i think
i don't even know i would look at it and
i'd be like you've got to be kidding
there it is on my reading list again
it's a critic it is a central part of
critical theory which is
rampant throughout all of academia now
it's found its way to secondary schools
you know pre-college and um it's it's
basically about taking whatever's in the
center pushing it to the margins and
putting something else to the center so
i think it's a way of reading and
looking at everything
so we've got critical theory and
critical race theory it ties into that
in particular now from my understanding
of critical race theory it started off
in the 1970s it was raised
it was posited as a theory as the 19 in
the 1970s in universities
why has it suddenly gone from a
university or college setting and bled
right the way through
into primary schools is what people have
told me in the us
right i i think i would call it downward
drift i think that things from the
academy tend you know it really i think
started in law schools i think derek
bell at harvard
as a way of
you know identifying certain laws that
have a disparate impact
which seems like a legitimate line of
inquiry but then it became extrapolated
to all of these other fields and a very
useful tool i think for dismantling
anything that some people want
dismantled
we have in america what are known as ed
schools education schools and
they tend at this point to be mono
cultures i had to get certain training
to become a k-12 teacher i was certified
as a english as an english teacher and
as a guidance counselor a counselor
and luckily i was well i didn't
completely bypass the ed schools but i
didn't as an undergrad go go to study
that and so so now it's in the ed
schools and these teachers are trained
in it and
i i can why is it now in the k-12
schools i a couple of reasons i think
that
teaching is a difficult career that a
lot of times does not come with a lot of
accolades and i feel like it's a way for
teachers to feel more significant and to
the extent that we don't make our
teachers feel significant i think that's
our fault
that
that's something we can correct uh you
know i i tend to not think that teachers
are as terribly underpaid as they like
to claim i think that teacher salaries
have risen to be you know the benefits
are really really great but i don't
think that we have a lot of respect for
teachers um i you know i i sense it
coming apart in our society between
teachers and parents between the up you
know charles murray wrote a book called
coming apart he's of course pretty
controversial but just about um you know
when i was a kid my parents would have
had our teachers over for dinner they
would have we would have gone to church
with them we would have been in the same
social networks but i think that
teachers are beginning to be perceived
as
less than and i think to some extent
this is a way for them to claim more
significance for themselves that's just
one i'm just that's one guess that i
have for why it's caught on
it's interesting bonnie wouldn't have i
mean a more
charitable interpretation might be that
some people would argue i don't
necessarily agree with this but some
people would argue that
um
for centuries probably or for decades at
least we were teaching kids
one particular version of events right
you were taught a particular version of
history a particular version of uh
various other subjects that had a
certain slant let's say a pro-american
slan in america or a pro-british line in
britain or a pro-russians line in russia
where i'm from uh and what these people
are doing are uh poking
uh or pointing out rather the holes in
some of those narratives that you know
you you can't teach an eight-year-old
all the complexities of history so you
have to give them a simple narrative
right about certain things and what
these people have done is rightly expose
some of the gaps in those narratives
that we used to teach to our children in
the past
yes that is one of the arguments that is
used to justify it and i do think that
there are teachers who are doing it for
those reasons uh i think that there are
other teachers who are doing it with
more
activist aims
i think that um when it becomes
problematic is when it is presented as
the only
perspective with which to view
historical events and when students are
asked to affirm this is the correct
point of view uh and then we get into
what you know at fire the foundation
where i work what we would call
compelled speech
where you know you know which is sort of
what you were describing when teachers
are being told they must list their
pronouns now some people are going to
say well that violates my
values my religious upbringing because
you know in the bible it says that there
are two genders and what not and so
you're basically asking them to affirm a
worldview that they may not agree with
uh and in america that is you know so
there are lawsuits happening right now
on these very issues and we'll see how
those turn out
bonnie isn't the problem as well and
look uh i was a teacher i was a teacher
for 12 years i taught in secondary
school i also taught in primary schools
isn't part of the problem the fact that
most teachers are left-leaning you're
it's very rare to get a teacher who
leans right
i mean that's just the nature of
of the people that the profession
attracts so obviously they're going to
be more tended to look at the world in
this way
through a critical lens using critical
pedagogy
right and this is a big problem why are
other people not showing up for the
teaching profession uh the ed schools
really are
pretty much a monoculture at this point
i think it's like a snowball i think
that we've known for decades that it
tilted left but it's almost at the point
where it reaches such a spiral that
there's only one viewpoint being uh you
know being presented at all and we are
at that point now and probably you know
and can we come back from it because so
many students now look they might be
interested and they say i'm not going to
be welcome it's it's ironic because you
know inclusivity is such an important
aspect of what they're arguing and yet
these ed schools are
so non-welcoming to anyone with
different points of view so they very
much are promoting diversity but many
people will point out it's unless it's
intellectual diversity or diversity of
thought that they're not interested in
and bonnie how much do you think of this
you know we've covered the culture war
stuff a tremendous amount on on the show
and one of the things that's become
increasingly clear if you look at the
surveys and the polling and and the data
on it is that uh particularly on this
sort of stuff there's a sex dynamic
going on and the women are far more
likely to skew in this direction so in a
profession that has always been
dominated by women
and will likely be dominated by women
for all eternity i imagine
that isn't i guess what francis is
getting at what i'm also getting at
isn't this just an inevitable
consequence of the fact
that the teaching profession attracts a
particular type of person more likely to
be female and more likely to lean left
on political issues and so schools will
always have that sort of pen inevitably
i guess
well and it's it's so interesting
because that's the argument that they're
making in favor of diversity but half of
the students are male and nobody's
arguing in terms of improving the
representation of males in the classroom
i did pull the numbers on this in my
book and uh the teaching ranks are even
when i when i was in elementary school i
think i really benefited
maybe unfairly from the fact that a lot
of incredibly intelligent women were
still stuck in teaching careers because
other pathways weren't open to them so i
think i really did have uh excellent
teachers who may be in a different era
might have become doctors or lawyers uh
and
you would think now that women have a
lot more career paths open to them that
fewer of them would be in teaching but
believe it or not the teaching ranks in
america are even more female now than
they were when i was in elementary
school
and i think that we need to do a
campaign an advertising campaign maybe
even some sort of affirmative action
encouragement to get more males into the
classroom
for every number of reason including
just positive role modeling for
the male students who in america are
under performing uh and you know the
outcomes for them are much worse than
for females coming out of k-12 and going
on to college as well males are are in
increasing numbers rejecting college
they got affirmative action for men
that's going to be a great policy
good luck selling that body yeah
thank you
hey francis would you like to learn
another language no mike i already know
foreign language is perfectly
gary a
biblioteca
you can't go on holiday mate without
knowing where the swimming pool is the
bible tech is the library you idiot
exactly you can never be too far away
from knowledge and sexually frustrated
librarians
for those of you who do want to learn a
language and connect with another
culture or maybe just brush up in your
spanish for the next holiday babble is
the app for you babble's 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babble designs
their courses with practical real world
conversations in mind things you're
going to use in everyday life like
finding out where the bibliotheque is
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts meaning real people so
you learn useful vocabulary and not
meaningless phrases like the ones
francis keeps uttering babel's teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italians and the other ones babel
is available as an app or online and
your progress will be synced across all
devices babel is offering our listeners
six months free with a purchase of a six
month subscription with our promo code
which is trigger go to babble.com
forward slash play and use promo code
trigger for an extra six months for free
we're even gonna get francis on it you
might learn english
that's b a b b e l dot com forward slash
play promo code trigger i use babble and
look at me now yo bordeaux
absolutely
gary
i think the problem is bonnie and this
comes from experience the fact that
teaching isn't a very good job anymore
let's just call it what it is you know
the behavior of students is atrocious
you look down upon your demeaned on a
daily basis by parents
uh you're not respected i mean the pay i
would push back the pay i can only talk
from a uk perspective hasn't gone up in
years
it's naturally going to attract these
sorts of people because you you look at
it from an outsider point of view if
you're in the center or maybe in the
center right or you and
you want to make money you want and you
want to have a successful career you
look at teaching you think well why
would i get involved in it quite rightly
in my opinion as someone who's
experienced it right well i mean my
husband and i have been in academia in
education for
pretty much our whole careers and
he is a professor he's
likely to retire soon uh and yeah i mean
the demands have increased to an
intolerable level the student
misbehavior has increased i think that
there are intrinsic rewards to teaching
but i do think that some teachers are
trying to enhance these intrinsic
rewards by making it sort of a political
battle that they're waging via the
classroom seeing students as means to
the end you know the world that they
want to uh to bring to bring into
um
being but and you know i don't like the
war analogy but i would say that you
know if this is a culture war then this
is one of the fronts on which it is
being waged and we need soldiers uh i i
the i will say in america the benefits
for teachers are quite good and there
are still pensions and things that
aren't available in other careers so i
hope people will consider it and i i
hope that you know the families i get
discouraged when i talk to families who
are very angry about what's going on in
their children's schools and i'm
starting to say to people well would you
encourage your children to become
teachers and they sort of scoff at me
and i'm like well
as long as we you know abandon the field
then this is what we're going to get so
uh if you really care about
the principles that undergird this
country and it's not just this country i
would argue it's western civilization
then we probably need to i i hesitate to
say take up arms but you know man the
stations and show up we have to show up
and uh and account and stand up for what
we believe in
and you say
and look i'm i'm with you a hundred
percent the fact that a classroom
is not a place of education but a place
to spread political ideas and political
doctrine to me is tantamount to child
abuse and brainwashing your job as a
teacher is not there to tell kids what
to think your job as a teacher is to
tell teach them how to think
that's what you do as a teacher and then
carry on yeah your job is to deliver the
curriculum that you were hired to
deliver that is democratically agreed
upon within the community as
administered through the school board it
like as i was writing my book i kept the
the subtext in my mind is this is not a
free for all people you don't just wing
it you're not just making it up you're
not there to expound on your opinions no
one cares what your opinions are you are
there to deliver the curriculum to teach
critical thought not critical pedagogy
but let me push back on what francis
said because a lot of people might say
well yeah you say that you know
education is supposed to be about
teaching kids how to think but that's
not really what happens in the school
what happens in the school is you sit
down and you get told what the right
version of this particular event is or
what the right interpretation of a
particular historical period is or or
you know why these people did this or
why and there's plenty of other ways of
looking at that same thing you know i'm
a huge fan of history and i read a lot
about history a lot of the stuff that i
was told in school was complete rubbish
right and not only that not only was it
rubbish but it also skewed in a
particular direction so isn't that not i
mean i would argue
and this is where i might agree with
some of the people on that side is
we've always been indoctrinating kids we
just were indoctrinating them with a
particular vision and now we don't like
the fact that people are indoctrinating
with a different vision that we don't
like now i personally don't like the
version that they're being indoctrinated
indoctrinated with now either i'm just
saying
can we honestly pretend that there was
this golden age of education where it
was all neutral and there was no
indoctrination going on and suddenly now
kids are being indoctrinated isn't it
more a case of like we just don't like
the fact that they're being
indoctrinated with values that we would
consider
anti-antithetical to our civilization
but it's i think probably unfair to
pretend they weren't being indoctrinated
before
yeah i mean school is always about
instilling the agreed-upon
values of the community
what's interesting now is that i think
that they're teaching kids
to tear down the society
which is
which is why you're seeing parents
showing up in on mass at school board
meetings and they're some of them have
gotten you know a little bit out of hand
uh and i think the the crucial
difference though is the role of dissent
and you know the ability to speak back
to the narrative that you are talking
about because these are not religious
schools and it's almost like this is
being taught as though it's a state
religion in fact some people are
starting to say that the way to uh reign
this in is to have it declare to state
religion because this ideology does have
some religious aspects to it and to say
well in america we don't have a state
religion that is being taught in our
schools which is uh has been the subject
of many court cases and you know even
the pledge of allegiance which is a
rather
quaint but somewhat strange american
tradition where we stand up and say a
pledge to the flag
has been pushed back against uh via
jehovah's witnesses and there's a very
eloquent court case
west virginia versus barnett where you
know they say that
if there's any fixed star in our
constitution it's that no
no authority
high or low
shall prescribe what shall be orthodox
so in america we've traditionally left
room for the eccentric dissenter to
be left alone to have their space to say
their piece uh and i i like to say when
i was a teacher like for example i had
to teach some evolution and occasionally
i would have or i thought i might have
some fundamentalist students in the
class and i'd i would just jokingly say
you know i'm going to go over this it's
in the curriculum you need i said you
don't have to believe it but it's going
to be on the test you got to know it and
that's i think the difference here you
know you all have your podcast where you
get to say what it is that you think but
a really big problem that we're having
and i work at basically a free speech
organization so i would never say that
students don't have the right to bring
up critical theories or that a teacher
can't tell students that you know here's
a contrasting viewpoint on this
uh but to present it positively as
though it is um you know fundamentally
the right view to adopt is
misguided um and you know that's where
it veers into inculcating a doctrine
which is exactly what indoctrination is
bonnie we've been talking
back and forth and it's been fascinating
but i'm sure there's lots of people who
are listening to this who are thinking
well just give me some examples what
actually are you talking about when
you're talking about indoctrination for
example because you know that's a very
big word
you know that has serious connotations
to it
yeah we keep lists
so that i can keep up on it and you know
there are several lawsuits that are
proceeding right now in the united
states
um
i mean
some examples i have a lot of examples
of lying you know
where
lessons are being kept secret from
parents
and it's been documented for example in
missouri there was a school
administrator who
told
district teachers to create fake lesson
plans and post them online so that they
wouldn't have to receive any questions
from parents about what was actually
going on in the classroom and what was
actually going on bonnie this is i think
what francis is getting that is what are
the kids actually being taught
okay so um
we have six-year-olds who are being told
they can choose their own gender behind
their parents backs one of the things
that's happening this school year is
it's been exposed that there are gender
plans where students have a different
identity at school and a different name
at school than they have at home and the
schools are keeping this secret from the
parents
six-year-old
uh
all well all ages in terms of the
secretive gender plans so
yeah children in first grade being this
is the sexualized stuff that i'm looking
at right now children in first grade
being taught about masturbation um we
have there's been a lot of uproar this
year about books which i know it sounds
like book burnings but just age of
inappropriate books that depict sex
between an adult and a minor um we had
can i just interrupt you there so
part of when you train as a teacher in
the uk you get taught about something
called safeguarding
and safeguarding uh is where you it's
about the welfare of children and in
that you you you get taught about
grooming
that is an example of grooming is where
you take somebody who is not sexually
mature who is a child a very young child
has no concept about sex and procreation
or the rest of it and you teach them
about masturbation that to me
it's it's it's vile
yeah and if if you're interested in that
uh james lindsay had has done three
podcasts on our groomer schools that i
would recommend people take a look at
it's very upsetting and it really uh you
know it is
according to him and he's done a deep
dive into the readings is intended to
really divide
parent from child um which is a very
vile aspect of it uh there are classes
where they are shaming and labeling
students according to their skin color
they are divided there have been classes
where students have been divided
according to skin color and you know
this violates
civil rights laws that we have in the
united states um one of the weird
examples that came to me in my job was
a student we had we've had a couple of
walkouts uh in the united states this
one was over gun control wanting gun
control and uh it was supposed to be
students walking out in favor of gun
control voluntarily and then taking the
consequences but in this case the
administrators decided this is a great
idea we're going to walk out too and
everyone has to come with us and it was
a student who said but i don't agree
with this i believe in the second
amendment and
gun rights and i don't want to be forced
to walk around in
favor of you know forced activism
promoting something i disagree with and
um
so i told him to tell them that he tell
them that and so their solution was that
he could stand in the middle of the
track while the entire school would walk
in a circle around him because that was
what they had planned anyway and so i
told him to go to his guidance counselor
and the guidance counselor put an end to
that uh but we we do have curricula that
have been designed by outside
organizations for example black lives
matter is one um 1619 project is another
teaching
um
southern poverty law centers teaching
for tolerance i think it's now called
teaching for justice
and they have lessons that have raised a
number of concerns uh so many families
are now asking for greater transparency
about what's going on in the classroom
because the messages embedded in many of
these lessons are antithetical to what
families are often teaching at home but
bonnie why is it
that
you have outside organizations
dictating what is and what isn't taught
in a classroom and how it should be
taught that
i don't understand that they have no
place in the classroom right well
they're not dictating it these are
supplemental lessons that teachers adopt
voluntarily and then my question is well
where's the supervision where's the
department head where is the principal
where is the curriculum staff at the
district level and the school board
uh so this is that my classroom
thing that's happening uh but yeah i
mean i thought teachers were supposed to
for the most part create their own
lesson plans
well look bonnie we've addressed the
doom and gloom of how terrible
everything is and by the way uh that it
does sound bad like this six-year-old's
being taught about the gender options
and whatever else it is just to me
that's that that's outrageous but um
you're the the last part of the title of
your book is what we can do about it
so what can we do about it because the
reason i ask is please don't take any
offense at this but it seems to me like
in america you guys have gone pretty far
off the rails and the problem for us
here in the uk is we all have always
follow you like lemmings off the very
same cliff so we're gonna have to deal
with this what can we do about it yeah i
do think that we are are probably the
most advanced case of i guess woke
infiltration into our schools um well i
think that transparency is essential
sunlight they say is the best
disinfectant and so i you know if
teachers are trying to hide something
from you that's never a good sign
i think that there needs to be
coordination and camaraderie between
parents they should be working together
there's this concept of in loco parentis
where teachers are supposed to act in
the place of the parents uh but they
have really been uh improvising lately
my joke about that is that they uh put
the loco in in loco parentis
i mean obviously i would recommend
reading the book and sharing uh the
reasons that i detail and i pulled lots
of research on why this is not healthy
for students why this does not
amount to a substantive rigorous
effective education
but i was thinking about this right
before we got on and i think there are
four ways of addressing it there are the
legal legislative means of responding to
this there are bureaucratic means
um but ultimately this comes down to
really a cultural problem uh
you know we have
and then there are academic means you
know we need to get better or more
people in the classroom to balance
what's going on so that uh teachers who
think this is a good idea need to hear
the counter arguments
you know in america we have the
strongest free speech protections in the
world but those don't really mean
anything if you're afraid to use them
and what's happening is that
students are shaming other students
because they're learning that there's
one view that is the preferred view and
other views merit derision and ostracism
and ironically you know when my kids are
in school they're in their 20s now we
had a flurry of really the biggest
problem back then was this anti-bullying
program which probably sounds good
in theory it should be good but it was
very poorly implemented and they really
kind of trained students to demand that
they should never ever feel any
discomfort and if they ever do they
should run to an authority figure and
demand that somebody
redress this grievance and they sort of
learn to exaggerate anything that
happens whereas we were
trained in my generation more to just
tough luck stand up for yourself get
over it shake it off um maybe there's a
middle ground between those two
perspectives but i you know students are
bullying other students now i think with
the permission and encouragement of some
of the teachers and some of what's going
on is that teachers are you know shaming
labeling isolating and i would argue in
some cases bullying students which is
really really uh uncalled for and
unhelpful and so you know i think we can
do better than that
so there are a number of um lawsuits
underway we have a flurry of legislation
proposed at the state level which itself
can prove problematic like maybe it's
going to cause a backlash that's its own
problem because they're banning crt in
the classroom you know anything
some of these are better written than
others but they some of them
are written in a way to say that we will
not teach anything that argues that one
race is superior to another race uh in
this case they're arguing that the white
race is inferior
and deserves to have discrimination
against it well that violates you know
the 14th amendment in america and many
other laws that we have so
um bureaucratically people are filing
freedom of information act requests to
get their hands on curriculum
another big problem we're having that
you should watch for is these outside
consultants being hired to come into
schools
to deliver
ideas and curriculum that is not
democratically decided on and that's how
some of this finds its way into the
classroom and uh and then when parents
ask to see what is
being taught to the teachers uh they are
told that it's copyrighted so
we're having to you know
legislate saying that nothing that's
imported into the schools can be
shielded from the parents using
copyright as an excuse
um
yeah and bonnie
how what role are the unions playing in
all of this
are the unions supporting it are they
pushing back or are they simply
apolitical when it comes to this issue
no i don't think the unions are
apolitical at all um you know i can't
speak for everything going on in the
unions but at first there was a lot of
denialism going on oh that's not
happening you're imagining it what
people call gaslighting uh but then the
unions came out and said okay we it's
not happening and we're going to defend
the teachers who are doing it which is
kind of hilarious uh so when people say
it's not happening i i respond well then
why did the union say that they're going
to defend you know and they're arguing
that teachers have first amendment
rights but re in reality it's hired
speech they do in their personal lives
but in the classroom
they're paid to deliver the state
approved curriculum in a public school
bonnie i have a question as i'm i'm i'm
sort of
watching us have this conversation and
it's a very interesting one and the the
nuances are interesting but if i'm a
parent
what i'm really want to
hear here is not even how i can
participate with other parents and
changing the system what i'd be
interested in is like what the hell do i
do with my kids right now to avoid
having them in a situation where they're
being taught about you know sex at the
age of six and and being put on some
kind of gender part
whatever this craziness is like what
would what should parents do to protect
their kids that is their primary
responsibility right a couple of things
a lot of parents are pulling their kids
out when they can and homeschooling them
i know that's not an option for everyone
but we have pretty wide open uh options
to do that in the united states i would
argue that you can supplement your
child's curriculum to balance it to
provide the balance that isn't being
provided in school we have a number of
great curricular materials that we've
also created at thefire.org
curriculum that you can download and
this is mostly about first amendment
rights and about um you know the
constitution and uh the enlightenment
and where western values came from in
the first place
um
i i would also
say that um parents oh i on my website
indoctrinate.org
blog i have i've put together you know
the i'm like okay
i've been outlining their arguments
because i want to give their arguments
they're due i don't want to do the straw
man thing and just make a fake argument
and then
do it so you know that's something that
i'm working on and then i also said okay
they have
they're proposing certain systems that
they want to transform
uh our culture with and i'm like well
what are the systems that we have in
place that they are arguing against so i
do have eight different systems that i
think are are well worth reviewing like
our economic system our system of
advancement our culture our mode of
interacting with each other our mode of
figuring out what is true and what is
not true a lot of these are sort of
invisible because it's the water we've
been swimming in our whole lives but i
credit to them for i think throwing all
of this into stark relief because they
are advocating a completely different
way of life a completely different
system by saying that everything is
terrible
and so i you know i
i want people to understand and to begin
talking about you know what it is that
we believe in and making sure that if
you're going to reject it you know what
it is that you're rejecting
because i don't i think it's like
deconstructing the cannon it's i think
our kids are not being told what's great
about our way of life and that's what
i'd like to um tell parents that we need
to start doing
hey francis do you like coffee no mate i
like tea because tea is british this is
british there's kebabs and saint george
he's from india and china kebabs are
from the middle east and some george was
turkish doesn't matter mike you became
british after we smashed the crap out of
that lizard that's what happens when you
look at someone's bird during a night
out
good to know well for those of you who
have a more sophisticated palette than
francis i.e every single one of you if
you enjoy coffee then you have to check
out packed coffee packed coffee or an
award-winning specialist coffee delivery
company they have 100
specialty grade coffee freshly roasted
to perfection for your order and ground
just moments before it's shipped there
are over 15 different coffees on the
menu at any given time to choose from
including great taste 2020 and 2021
winners packed coffee buys its coffee
direct from farmers and cuts out steps
in the supply chain paying on average 65
above the fair trade base price ensuring
farmers are actually making a profit and
can reinvest in their farms to produce
even more delicious coffee tell your
vegan mates about pack it'll impress
them massively you can plan exactly how
you want your coffee and when it's
delivered to you it's not your typical
subscription that comes on the first of
every month or every wednesday you can
get coffee whatever you want at whatever
frequency you want and you can pause
cancel or change your plan anytime
online make a pack to make better coffee
we'll help you get started with a free
v60 kit worth 11 pounds and 40 free
filters with your first order go to
pactcoffee.com that is p-a-c-t
coffee.com create a flexible coffee
subscription enter the code trigger at
checkout and get a free brewing kit when
you create your subscription plan with
packed coffee and get speciality coffee
through your letterbox don't wait go to
packedcoffee.com
use a code trigger and create your
coffee subscription the code is valid
when you create a packed coffee plan
and bonnie do you think the solution is
for people to set up their own schools
for there to be more freedom to do that
and as a result of that they become more
successful because they're focusing on
on more traditional
things when it comes to education like
reading writing etc because i was
reading about a lot of your public
schools
and to me it sounds like a large part of
them are simply not fit for purpose when
you see people graduating from them
unable to read or write
people are talking about starting new
schools we do have something called
charter schools where you can set up a
school with its own charter where it has
a specific mission and some of these are
you know the mission is to transmit
traditional values i don't think they
can be religious but they have a
specific purpose and they are freed from
some of the restrictions of traditional
public schools uh it's it's hard you
know you can't make wave a wand and have
a school appear instantly we i hear from
many many parents who are asking that
exact question right now holy cow what
do i do even the private schools which
you know we have different levels of
private schools but even the wealthiest
private schools if you can't buy your
way out of this in the united states of
america right now no matter how much
money you have it tends to be even worse
in private schools this importation of
one-sided ideology uh and it seems to be
worse in affluent communities as well it
seems to be an affliction of um effluent
white
women
not entirely but those characteristics
predominate uh i mean you might consider
moving to a more rural area and actually
a lot of people in america if you look
at our population shift are moving to
places like texas or florida or uh
places that are right now more you know
freedom loving i guess you could
you could say so some people are voting
with their feet uh some people are
trying to set up new schools some people
are deciding i have to do it myself
but the window that was provided via
covid through zoom into our children's
classrooms
has revealed a really
unappealing reality and so it's been a
huge wake-up call and i i i think that
that didn't happen for no reason and so
hopefully it will lead to improvements
and and good consequences i know that
there are many many well-intentioned
good teachers out there and i certainly
don't want to impugn uh people who are
showing up and doing you know yeoman's
work every day
there's pressure on teachers too we hear
from teachers who are
being pressured to do things that make
them uncomfortable and we have seen some
a few very dramatic resignations i loved
my job but i can't do this to kids
anymore because i disagree fundamentally
with what's going on
and this is what i was going to ask you
i think
it might sound to the neutral observer
that we're kind of been beating up on
teachers
but how much of this
is about the broader culture so yes i
understand that a lot of these ideas
were initially developed in academia and
then started to spill out into broader
society but i almost feel like the
position we are in now
is it's spilling out of broader society
back into everything and i think
education is probably just another
branch into which it's now spelled out
because if you look at you can look at
anything you could you could sport look
at video games look at almost any other
issue these ideas are bleeding through
so how much of this is just like
education is
affected by this just like everything
else or is it a particularly special
case do you think
i think that education the media and
academia which obviously is education
are probably among the most left-leaning
thing you know or institutions in
america so i think it's a little bit
more advanced than it is in the rest of
the culture
which is why you see the uproar at our
school board meetings um
yeah so but but i do think too that a
lot of these young we're also seeing the
retirement of
a wave of teachers with the baby boom i
mean they're aging out and even though i
think they thought that they were very
radical for their time you have to ask
yourself who educated the baby boomers
they were mostly educated i'm
technically a baby boomer last three
months of the baby boom you know and i
was educated i realized now mostly by
people who fought in world war ii a very
patriotic generation and so that is
definitely part of my ethos part of you
know how i how i look at the world uh
whereas this generation is really
educated largely by baby boomers who
were radical so um
we have a wave of younger teachers
coming in and i i think part of it is
the deficit and how they themselves are
educated so i sympathize with the
deficiencies i think that they received
in their own education and i think we
need to help them to be better teachers
and bonnie we've spoken a lot about the
education we've spoken about teachers
we've spoken about systems but we
haven't really discussed what has been
the impact on children
because that's the most important thing
with this issue the kids right
so um apparently uh
there are is some research showing that
things like ethnic studies which is one
form that this takes
i'm hearing is
good for students um
which is concerning but it also speaks
to the fact that in academia we have
very few professors ed professors who
are looking at questions from the other
point of view
so
the need to conduct research there's not
much evidence on that i guess is what i
would say it's very difficult to conduct
research on children you have to get
their parents permission there's all
sorts of ethical
guidelines that have to be followed
so
there is a darth of evidence it's mostly
anecdotal at this point um i think that
kids i mean
how many kids can articulate what's
wrong with their own education in
elementary school virtually none
we do have students who reach out to us
at fire for help there is a group of
students called students unite where
that i would recommend
people check out if they're looking for
like-minded students who are
unhappy with what's going on in their
schools who are frustrated with it
um
so yeah i think that the the chance for
harm is real and palpable and it needs
to be studied and measured
i completely agree with you because
that's a worrying thing you know we're
talking about
what they're teaching we're talking
about the way kids are being taught
but we've got no idea what we're going
to harvest with these kids
yeah and and and how intimidating it is
to know you know i talk about in my book
um unconditional acceptance and when i
was trained as a counselor that is sort
of the fundamental
foundation of any helping relationship
counseling teaching those are helping
professions and unconditional acceptance
just means if you come to me and you're
like i am an alcoholic it's like
okay that's where you are right now it's
like you don't help someone by saying
god what kind of
weak-willed idiot are you to be an
alcoholic
you know and if a student comes to you
and
they can't read okay you're in third
grade you don't read okay that's where
you are we're just gonna start there and
we're gonna move forward as best we can
you accept them but this is
un this is conditional acceptance you're
only acceptable to me if you
uh play the role that i require you to
play so students naturally
want to be
you know appreciated and liked by their
teachers so they're playing roles and
this is this whole idea of
inauthenticity so i think that we're
inculcating really unhealthy behaviors
uh and how many of us how
here's something that a parent said to
me once that really made me worry she
was very much on our side of the issue
very concerned well
she's very concerned about i said that
was the wrong way to say that she was
very concerned about what's going on in
her child's schools
and she wants someone to fix it but she
finished the conversation by saying
how can i
tell my child to be very careful of what
he says in school
so that it doesn't
and that's how she ended it and i said
so that it doesn't hurt your career
and she said yes
my husband's career and i mean this is
the type of warning
and i said to her well i think that our
goal is to change the culture so that
you don't have to tell your son or
daughter this was a son
to be careful what he says in school
like what are you afraid that there's
the teachers and informant
is this
east berlin is this the eastern bloc
i mean
what kind and this is and i think that
so many of us now are careful of what we
say because we're afraid that we're
going to be you know dragged through the
public humiliation mill reviled um you
know we did actually have a professor
who was a fire case um who was a very
outspoken professor and was often
described as being a happy warrior
and he fought and fought with his school
i don't even remember the circumstances
of it but i think he was called a racist
or you know we're all afraid of being
labeled a racist right
and he won his case but then he would
they asked him to leave and they gave
him a severance and he went home and he
committed suicide um so
and that was a big shock to everyone
because he did not seem like he was
bothered by what was going on because he
was he was provocative and he seemed to
be inviting it but yet
he
was clearly very
you know harmed by by what occurred so
i i think the invisible effects of
what's happening are going to be
lingering and are going to really impact
the life development of many young
people and it is quite quite
extraordinary what you're talking about
because
i i'm just finishing my book my first
book which is called an immigrants love
letter to the west and the opening
chapter
uh i talk about growing up in the soviet
union in the early 1980s and literally i
describe my parents having that
conversation with me as a young boy when
you go to school you must not repeat the
things that we talk about at home that
word for word that was the conversation
so to sit here in 2022 and to be
discussing america
and parents
thinking about what will happen to their
careers if their child says the wrong
thing at school to me that is an
extraordinary transformation of a
country that we traditionally associate
with as you say the strongest free
speech protections in the world
and yet you now have
children and parents afraid of wrong
think and wrong speak in public
houses how's this happen
it reminds me of that metaphor have you
ever heard about how if you catch crabs
you don't even have to put a lid on them
because
if you know if you catch one crab and
you throw it in a bucket he can't climb
out but if you catch three or four crabs
they could easily climb out but the
problem is that the other crabs will
pull them back in so you just keep
catching them and there's no lid
required and i think it's that same
analogy it's a cultural problem uh and i
think that it's
you know it's invisible and yet
oppressive and we can
and i think people are waking up and
shaking it off one by one but i promise
you that there are networks of people
talking privately saying
truths that they believe are trues that
they will not say publicly
and looking for trusted you know allies
to use that war metaphor again um to
help them in this fight but i
i do take heart because i think that
what really happened last year is that
like i've been trying to warn about this
for
when i i pulled my daughter out of her
school over the lying uh and that was 11
years ago so i really been trying to
bring attention to this for over a
decade now and last year was the year
when you know the the
sheet was pulled off and everything was
revealed and so my theme this year is
the cat's out of the bag now what do we
do about it and
anybody at this point who says it's not
happening in america anyway is really
behind where where the majority of
people are now it's like okay it is
happening and so now we're hearing okay
it is happening and it's good that it's
happening
which is fine you know that's what some
people think and then other people can
say at least we're having the same
conversation now uh about what's going
on
and are you optimistic you mentioned the
lawsuits i imagine that in the at the
end of the day yes it's a cultural
problem but partly cultural problems
often get resolved through
land you know landmark legal decisions
right are you expecting to see that
happen over the next year or so i think
so we have a couple of cases one is uh
that people are watching closely is in
nevada this is a biracial boy the mother
is black and the father was white the
father's deceased and he was told to
confess his white privilege in class and
he refused and was threatened with
failure so you know you've got harm and
um and
this case kind of runs the table on
every uh law that can be invoked and it
also has the um
very sympathetic appearance of you know
because it's happening to a lot of
people who do not fit into the bike
category that
supposedly these people are trying to
protect his his appearance is white but
he's biracial and so it's a very
interesting case um
so yeah i think we're going to have some
legal decisions and i think you know and
actually quite a few teachers have lost
their jobs over going too far and i
don't think enough attention has been
brought to that one example is the the
so-called antifa teacher who was caught
on camera bragging about he says i have
180 days to turn these kids into
revolutionaries and he uh was you know
offering them extra credit to go to
protests and rallies and things like
that so um when it was exposed that you
know he was using his class to
radicalize students he was fired so i i
have multiple examples of teachers who
have lost their jobs for exceeding the
boundaries of what they were hired to do
um
so little by little i think uh
improvements are being made but
uh this this problem has been with us i
know um you had said you know critical
race theory i guess 1970 that's pretty
accurate i think the real origins
probably go back as far as the 1930s uh
specifically in america teachers college
columbia with the frankfurt school and
antonio gramsci
who um
really sort of was trying to bring about
the cultural revolution they could never
understand why the worldwide revolution
hadn't happened with this you know the
soviet union yeah we're off to a great
start there and everyone else
right
um and it just didn't happen and they
said well that's because the culture the
culture needs to change and so they have
been chipping away at our culture
cultural underpinnings for you know that
many decades now about 90 years and so
this isn't this ship is not going to
turn around overnight but i don't think
it's going to take 90 years to turn it
around it is going to take a concerted
effort we do have a number of um very
concerned organizations you know
foundations donors who are coming
forward to say you know
we see what's going on now we definitely
want to turn this around and and that's
not to say that we want to go back to
just this one happy-go-lucky 1950s
positive
you know view of everything but you know
my view is time we need to restore
balance and we need to uphold standards
that's another front where they're sort
of saying you know uh get rid of grades
let's get rid of testing and because
it's not fair to say that some kids are
smarter than other kids and the great
leveling again and so balance and
upholding standards i think is the path
forward
bonnie i couldn't agree with you more
that is music to my ears it's been a
wonderful interview our final question
is always the same it's what's the one
thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
um i already alluded to this we need to
stop talking about i would like to
i've been talking about critical race
theory for a long time i'm ready to stop
talking about critical race theory and
start talking about what is awesome
about western civilization and
everything it has to recommend it we've
critiqued it enough we've critiqued it
so much that nobody even can articulate
what it is anymore so i want to start
and encourage others to uh start
extolling the virtues of western
civilization we're not perfect but we
are you know as as winston churchill
said compared to what
it's the worst system except for
everything else
all right well i'll send you my book
when it's out then because that's
exactly what it's about uh bonnie thank
you so much we're going to ask you a
couple of questions for our locals but
in the meantime if people want to check
out some of the resources you mentioned
or follow fire's work what's the best
place to follow up on this conversation
if people want to do that yeah please
visit uh thefire.org
k12 to see all of the materials we have
we're nonpartisan a non-partisan
nonprofit
and i have a site indoctrinate.org where
you can check me out as well
fantastic please do do that and of
course uh if you've enjoyed this
interview or even if you haven't we've
got more coming for you uh in the next
few days and weeks uh the interviews
always go out on a wednesday and sunday
and sunday at 7 p.m and we've got the
raw shows on thursday friday and
saturday as well so we will see you very
soon and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
how do you think the damage done to
children during the pandemic through the
wearing of masks loss of education loss
of in-person opportunities as well how
will that damage manifest itself in
later life do you think
oh wow
[Applause]